elle lie la fa bonjour on le disait
c'est donc aujourd'hui que la haute
autorité de santé doit rendre son avis
sur la pertinence du recours au test
salivaire dans la stratégie de prise en
charge de la maladie aux copies de 19
alors quel est l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement
écoutez olivier l'enjeu est capital pour
le gouvernement dont la stratégie
actuelle a montré ses limites vous
l'avez dit les taux de contamination
sont à la hausse
les files d'attentes interminables
devant lé laboratoire ou encore des
délais à rallonge pour obtenir les
résultats des tests alors si la haute
autorité de santé validé ces tests
salivaires il pourrait constituer une
alternative au test actuel par voie
nasale donc moins désagréable moins
dissuasive mais aussi plus rapide ce qui
pourrait résoudre les embouteillages
devant les laboratoires comme on a pu le
voir ici devant ce laboratoire de
neuilly sur seine où nous avons
recueilli quelques témoignages écouter
ça fait déjà une heure que je suis dans
la queue visiblement j'en ai encore pour
une heure bon faut avoir deux heures à
perdre comme ça en restant debout sont
sans bouger donc ça fait précisément une
heure ça fait beaucoup mais c'est plus
simple de venir jusqu'ici j'habite dans
le 93 mais c'est encore pire de se faire
tester là bas puisqu'il faut attendre
soit une semaine pour avoir les
résultats il n'y a pas de rendez vous
avant début octobre
ça fait deux heures de temps que
j'attends
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de monde
on est obligé de patienter de faire la
queue là aujourd'hui je ne travaille pas
je prends une journée juste pour faire
le test
oui parce que je savais que ça n'allait
pas être facile que ça le prend du temps
alors restait à déterminer quels publics
seraient concernés dans quelles
conditions ces tests salivaires serait
effectuée c'est ce qu'a déclaré hier
lors de la conférence de presse sur
l'île et les rangs le ministre de la
santé avec un enjeu capital pour l
exécutif il s'agit d'éviter à tout prix
nouvelle vague un nouveau confinement
qui aurait des conséquences désastreuses
sur l'économie
merci beaucoup il a faim pour toutes ces
précisions lille à faa'a musou en direct
de neuilly-sur-seine dans les
hauts-de-seine